my path my career prove that I can't
handle that the whitey told me that
stuff why did it give me an ego you know
I mean I don't have a ego why did he
give me why didn't make me believe that
stuff that I'm special well it's nothing
special about me I'm contrasting from
brown why did he tell me that why did I
graph to that why did I meet him with E
why am I here we got a great guest today
though yeah help me by the man listen
and come from a great area but I didn't
know the [ __ ] is in 1990 87 86 I knew
every rapper and the words nude it was
coming up and he lived in Tokyo
somewhere nobody now okay well we got
our man idk actually stands for
ignorantly delivering knowledge you
further say knowledge that's cuz that's
the only way these dumb [ __ ] are
listen you feel me yeah but listen if
nothing's really ignorant you know it's
like what was like Socrates saying that
he if don't know he knows that he don't
know mmm anything no one knows anything
oh I do what the man who knows something
knows that he knows nothing at all
absolutely true because when it comes to
the fact that how old are you no I'm 27
beautiful I had to become like partly 40
10 then I have to find out what is my
purpose here - not even my name but what
is mine what is my purpose in life then
knock people to make money to lose it
all to go broke to come back and make
more and then act like I'm bad I came
back or to learn from them be humble
what is I don't know damn that's always
changing for me to come back and be a
monster and get revenge and burn my
[ __ ] enemies down or is it to me to
thank them for put me in that position
to be enlightened I don't know hmm I
think it's the second one he if I was
the cheese you feel me down there well
tell us man what's it like being a young
up-and-coming rapper
oh you must feel like a God in a way you
know what's funny what's funny like
everything you saying about being humble
and stuff I was just having this
conversation with somebody about money
right so like I'm just now coming into a
little bit of money you know what I'm
saying I'm the first millionaire in my
family
you know and thank you and I literally
was like man I'm glad it's happening
when I'm 27 and not 17 actually when I
was 17 I went to jail for armed robbery
I've been in jail like three times I've
been a state prison in Maryland
everything just a baby to a kid like 17
I got charged as an adult for robbery
and uh you know basically could have
thrown my life away but I was able to
turn it around I thank God for that
situation because it made me way more
humble and it also made me patient it
made me understand him and maybe victory
to humble and meet you I'm aware lurked
great um I think I'm that's real - I
think I was afraid when I went in I
think when I left and I came out I was
more determined than afraid like I think
that's the reason why I had the courage
to do music because I knew that it would
be hard to get a job you know what I'm
saying
uh uh you know let alone I'm already a
black male in the area that I'm in and
then on top of that I have a felony you
know what I'm saying something like yo
where will I work how am I gonna get a
job how am I gonna do anything
luckily in jail I learned how to rap I
was writing music and stuff all the
inmates used to want me to like rap for
him so it was like a Friday like
everybody's like yo yo I see you writing
all the time freestyle like spit some
[ __ ] like you got three books and I was
nervous at first and I got over my fear
from that so by the time I got out it
was like okay
I can try this I can step into this and
it took me like really like seven years
to really see something significant from
it but I kept going and what I did was I
used that little bit of in
Karishma that would come from small
accomplishments to keep me going because
there were so many times I wanted to
quit and I was depressed I thought like
I was wasting my time I thought of my
life I wasn't gonna be [ __ ] even though
I was trying hard the music wasn't
catching the way that I needed it to and
one little thing like a fan might say
something nice to me or somebody might
reach out to me like wale say oh you
know I like your music I'm paying
attention I'm like damn you know about
me and then it'd be like a blog like
fader magazine or post me or something
just little things like help spark and
then keep going and it'd be like you
know how like um you're trying to learn
somebody to something and you just put a
little bit of bait and a little bit of
bait and a little that's that would be
the bait until I finally came to where
I'm at now and I still got a long way to
go but I'm here you know let me tell you
something about it's so funny that you
said that yeah Wow
you know I came when I first started
boxing you know I mean Carol just locked
up I learned I was discovered in boxing
I was 12 years old and I was boxing with
a guard there who's a professional boxer
and we were boxing he started teaching
me how to box and one day I broke his
nose and wife said I don't want you
boxing him no more and so he took me to
somebody else and the discipline this
guy for some reason I was a guy at the
street guy Rob still do anything she's
jumped I was a savage I was amongst in
the white kid I didn't love myself
that's why I showed it by acting like a
savage and um the sole weight Italian
guy said um he told me I was handsome he
thought I was handsome and he told me
and he told me I was good and he gave me
a 5 or 6 some life affirmations and then
all of a sudden I thought my name should
be raining without examiner grating
Achilles where did that come from
how did that happen and I'm nobody I'm a
bum my mother and my father were nothing
this guy told me a few words and I I
took those words in and now I think I'm
a car don't let me see a mirror I wasn't
I never saw a mirror I didn't love I'm
self are I'm so madly in love with
myself I turned into a monster
I had to be humbled
and still I guess no it's not you don't
even have a good guard is jealous of me
because I'm reaching up to its level no
I'm not gonna stop I'm never gonna start
tonight
daddy's had to keep getting humbled and
keep your number and then I felt myself
here empty with nothing broken and yes a
what the hell am I doing here
there should be dead man why am I here
you know man I'm not meant to be humble
men are meant to be humbled yeah you
know that's real well the universe will
certainly do that oh there's no doubt
the universe have you think here the
baddest [ __ ] that God hath
existed to being on your knees clang oh
god please have mercy on my soul yeah
yeah it's funny you say that that says
me when I went to jail it was like I
thought I was this that and the third my
mother used to say you know you know
don't do this you're gonna get in
trouble
obviously the [ __ ] that every you know
mother says and I'm 17 I'm like man like
I'm that's why I'm not gonna get caught
and I remember she would always say if
you ever go to jail I'm not bailing you
out I'm never gonna call you I'm gonna
disown you
I went to jail and I was the things I
was in my head and immediately like you
said it humbled me because I'm like damn
I'm in this environment I'm the only one
I'm by myself I'm scared I don't want to
do all these other different inmates is
trying to test me and they all together
I'm by myself I'm like damn that humbled
me like I'm like I'm not what I keep
trying to be or thought I was and I'm
just a human being like everybody else
you know what I'm saying and the only
person that had my back in that
situation not my friends nobody that I
was with when everything happened it was
my mother you feeling I'm saying so I
know without that situation I will that
was the first test that I think I got
from God humble in me you know that was
the first time I really saw myself feel
like okay I need to tone it down and get
it together and think differently I've
had probably three or four more times
when that happened especially with music
you know you'll see things going crazy
everything is going good you know people
so much.you you start feeling like you
don't have to hit certain people back
you know under saying you feeling like
you you don't have to respond at certain
text or whatever you you walking and
thinking you that's down a third and
then you drop that one song that doesn't
do nothing and then nobody's talking to
you no more in the way that happened so
many times back and forth with me to
where I learned that on the way down a
lot of these same people you know
they're gonna be around looking at me I
need to uh you know be grateful for all
the accomplishments but always know that
it could go away and I need to have a
plan for that one that happens this
music industry is people expect it to be
like this and it's not that it's
literally no it's not like that or it's
like oh no listen no listen it's what
you wanted to be you create the way you
want it to be you believe that it's like
this and that so it will be that gap for
you you forget though forget about
believing like that only remember being
this way and it'll be that way for you
your thoughts in your mind is your life
you just signed a deal right yeah I
literally just did a joint venture with
Warner Brothers meaning I have my own
label I'm a 50/50 partner and I own my
Master's mm-hmm you know awesome yeah
so this is the next chapter of your test
right here yeah
because this is when you're gonna start
to get the money again people are gonna
start to know who you are right people
are gonna be reaching out to you
everybody's gonna be loving you and this
is like you know right now it feels good
but it's also like I know that it
doesn't need to make me feel like I'm
better I don't know how to explain it
like I got a new crib and it's a really
nice spot everyone loves to come there a
lot of people there yeah and Mount
Olympus
the only ones like right now right now
I'm the only one and it's like I'm young
nah so I beat you know I fight people
over and I it don't matter how many
followers you got if I fight with you if
I like you if I if I'm inspired by you I
show you love you feel me and that's
kind of where I'm at with it like I
admire you made you made a great deal of
money or you have a ability to make a
lot of money okay it had white flight up
T or something right there I was gonna
say though with money though one thing I
trained myself to kind of one way I
trained myself to think before I came
into it I always was thinking like this
so you know how people say when someone
has a lot of money and someone doesn't
have a lot of money we look at them
equal you're supposed to all be equal we
all human I kind of feel a little bit
differently so when I see somebody at
McDonald's working right and they're
like um they're busting ass they're
doing everything they got to do they got
a smile on their face and I'm working
and I'm getting whatever I want to get
from them you know ordering my food
whatever the case may be I don't look at
that person equal to me I actually look
at that person above me why is that
because I don't know how I could work
for that amount of money every day and
probably have a family and kids that I
gotta feed and have a smile on my face
so a person that can do that to me is a
special person that I want to strive to
be like that's interesting that's
interesting so let's go through another
scenario okay you don't know who that
person is you don't know what he woke up
to this morning
right you know what if he came from
another country and his whole family's
been tortured I cut the pizza and
somebody from a different clan right now
he's there I have no idea we need to
know these peoples life I can't make
judgment of their life why he's down
there why he's working maybe he loved
them maybe that's his livelihood that's
his life possession is working
I mean therefore doesn't mean that's a
theory of him accomplishing something
right right right my shift I look at
that and I see em I don't know what I
think might say somebody working hard I
look at me I feel that's me that's my
mother that's my father right that's
more than my mother and father right
right right I mean and so why am i doing
so well and he's and he's in that
situation but I don't know it's life so
I can't say maybe he's in a good
situation
maybe he's happy he has a job to feed me
family we don't know it no one's
situation stuff could I look at this
when I was younger and I had quote quote
when I was poor and living in the cuoco
ghetto and I had nothing I was blessed
and so I became quote quote the Mike
Tyson quote quote rich and famous and
then I became cursed so what if they
deal with that hmm so what's the deal
with that when I was poor I was blessed
than when I was wealthy I supposedly
made it then I became cursed mmm so how
does that become about how does that
happen yeah it's my lifestyle I'm living
my lifestyle is my gin my soul is my
spirit it's not corrected in the way God
wants it to correct right it has to be
brought back to his justice has to be
brought back to her melody hmm I'm
blessed everything's good I'm getting
rocked up but I'm blessed I'm with the
right people always hurting me nobody's
doing this and that to me but I'm
blessed I should be dead before I even
started boxing knew I was a kid I should
be dead why am I not dead no my other
friends are yeah hmm well I think
there's two things I'm not smart these
guys was in school these guys who I
never went to school I was an idiot
couldn't read and write for twelve
thirteen fourteen so why did the wise
these guys are smarter than me they got
good families you know me they didn't
have to rob and steal but they did it
anyway so why did they do that I had to
I had nothing to do I had no food at
home I had no family searched my
mother's a prostitute my father's a pen
they don't care really about it there
huh why did God give them the [ __ ]
ability to believe they could have
children and raise children how did they
believe they can take care of kids what
the [ __ ] were they thinking well when
you were a kid you would probably say
that you had a certain type of mental
thought pattern at some point like you
talked about when cus started lifting
you up telling you what a handsome kid
you are what a great boxer you
be all that and you started to believe
it and you started to view yourself in
the eyes yes awesome she leads a talent
listen yes let me it's one thing why
would he tell me that I can't handle
that stuff I really that's my my my my
path my career prove that I can't handle
this - why'd he tell me that stuff why
did he give me an ego
you know I mean I don't have ego why did
he give me why did he make me believe
that stuff that I'm special
well there's nothing special about me
I'm from trash I'm from Brownsville why
did he tell me that why did I graph to
that why did I meet him who is he why am
I here it's a lot of questions to do
what you're doing what am i doing being
you know you're just being you're just
speaking your truth man
yeah and that brings me to the second
part of it first of all you had certain
mental thought you had sort of you had a
specific thought patterns that puts you
on a trajectory to become the world
heavyweight champion then you had new
thought patterns created because you
started you had the dream was realized
you had all the money and all the access
you could ask for then what
why wasn't I happy why didn't I make
that I was told that what's gonna make
me happy because that has nothing to do
with that made me miserable
yes that was miserable Wow hate myself
Wow why do I have all this money they
don't have anything these people don't
have anything why do I have all this
money I'm nothing I don't have an
education I'll do anything that people
I'm bad to people why do I have to why
is God blessing me with this this god I
don't deserve this heart I've deserved
I've heard so many people since I was a
baby all my life I've been I've been uh
objective the law my whole life I've
been the [ __ ] I've been I've been a
family my whole life my mother my father
we've all been involved the crime which
brings me to the universe higher power
spirit whatever it is has a plan for you
hide you pissant beyond what we think it
is you know you get into a certain thing
in life and you start thinking oh this
is it
this is where I'm supposed to be this is
who I am this is what I do and the next
thing you know the universe is showing
you you know what that was a good little
platform we got to but you know what
this is the next thing right so we got
to go here now and maybe that means your
mindset turns really dark and you get
really angry at something that in the
moment you might not understand why
you're angry I have everything in the
world why am i angry well because you're
not where you're supposed to be mm-hmm
there's some aspect of that that is no
longer useful on the path where you're
supposed to go you know and for you
idk ya mind if I call you J yeah you
come you sure so yeah but you know cuz
this is for you man you have a great
opportunity as far as with your mind set
and your awareness of your position and
what you've been through on your journey
through life to get you to here 27 years
old unbelievable record deal for
yourself the first millionaire of your
family that's [ __ ] huge man yeah those
are common sense and you have an
opportunity you have with the awareness
you can set your attention towards your
intention whatever that might be you
know and because we get blinded by all
the material [ __ ] yeah in our life you
know the money the women the the house
the cars the parties the look of being
successful yeah and the truth is that if
we can stay grounded stay stay locked in
stay tethered to the thing that you are
in the universe whatever that is man
maybe it's just for you to get this
message out through your music right
right
you know man you want me to speak on
that rope absolutely so it's funny I
thought about this and I'm a spiritual
person I believe that there was a God
higher being whatever you want to call
it I feel like I was put on this earth
to walk in the darkness in order to
bring people to us to the light
almost look at myself as a sheep in
wolf's clothing not a wolf in sheep's
clothing but a sheep in wolf's howl I
feel because I went through a lot of
darkness and I've done a lot of things
but my intention is always good now like
especially now like everything I do
everything that I talked about
everything that I've been through here's
an example back home right I'm not from
the hood I'm from a middle-class family
like your friends I was one of those
kids that didn't have to do none of this
stuff I was doing it but I felt like I
wanted to when I went to school and PG
if you don't go to a private school even
if you live in a good neighborhood
you're going to a bad school all of my
kids into private schools all the public
schools is bad so so listen I already
all that all that you know you already
know so listen so listen with me they
bringing guns to school all that so look
with me I'm literally in a situation
where I already don't get good grades in
class I'm already like getting in
trouble you know doing little things so
now when you throw me in a high school
full of other troublemakers and they
from the hood I'm not gonna hang out
with the honor roll students I'm not I
don't have I'm not I don't know
interested in that so I'm I'm hanging
out with the [ __ ] from the hood and
they like making fun of me cuz where I'm
from or where I live and I'm like I
gotta prove myself so I'm doing worse
stuff than they doing you feel them
saying but I went to jail and college in
the same year state prison and college
in the same year that's a perspective
not a lot of people have being middle
class and going through what I've gone
through but then still being able to
relate to [ __ ] from the hood because I
went to jail I can talk all to jail they
go I can tell you about the hookups and
all the different ways people eat and
order like different things that you
would only know when you're in jail I
can talk about that so they feel like
they can relate to me and then when I
say look but I'm a millionaire now I was
able to turn all that into this you can
do the same thing now
those people who probably couldn't
relate to anybody else who had money
except for people I was going the wrong
thing can look at me and say okay maybe
I can do the same thing and that's an
example of being a sheep in wolf's
clothing
it's like I appear as a wolf because of
what I went through you know if you look
at my videos and stuff you probably
think I do this standard third if you
meet me you'll see that I'm really not
all of that I'm I'm a nice person I have
a good heart I have compassion and I'm
trying to help people at the end of the
day you know what I mean if I was a
straight sheep and everything was right
and I was doing everything good and I
would be just like all those other
people that's telling these kids in the
hood a go to college and don't do this
and that I get a job better a lot to
them they can't relate to that you know
me they can't just relate to that if
that was the case all of them would be
doing it they wouldn't be looking up the
drug dealers
you feel me but if they could see like
oh yeah I'm living a life similar to it
I guess a drug dealer would live but a
little bit better and not illegal and I
don't have to worry about going to jail
for the things that I'm doing it now
they're like oh man maybe I could if I'm
telling it enough I can do that and then
maybe he helped me maybe when I get
there I could help somebody else and we
keep the cycle going you fellow sangre
yeah that's kind of where I'm at with it
right now man at this point in my life I
do music I don't do music for money I
know a lot of people say that but I'll
here's an example I didn't even know I
was making money before I signed a deal
I was making decent money like for you
know like if you want to compare it to
someone with a really good job I was
making a decent money like I think like
like before I got sign I made like five
hundred thousand that year you know what
I mean and that's a lot too you know for
a lot of people how are you getting your
music out there then anyway possible
Spotify use that of course ever just
marketing myself a lot of his words
about how do you know telling me you
ever get on like those teen show awards
and stuff never I want to I want to
heaven how do you how did you come to
like everything you do yeah it seems you
know and we all have our
mmm-hmm with this your music is a camera
guy right there
yes do you want to come in guy Gus
that's good you can tell them more
advise it right there you guys want your
camera guy yeah yeah just a head
[ __ ] could send me some stuff do it
all the night I wouldn't have to steer
it event mics here and he knows you've
been taking all of this Mack welding
stuffs what what do you mean dude Evan
hey what do you got my ship for Evan
what are you doing my shirt ever why are
you doing this it's taking my schedule I
know you've been taking my shirt for a
while
keep the shirts okay okay listen let's
make sure this never happens again
yes sir okay yes sir thank you so much
thank you
two for 20% off your first order visit
Mack Weldon calm and her promo code
Tyson for 20% off your first order
now that's Mack Weldon calm with promo
code Tyson for 20% off your first order
where did the music start for you did it
start in writing raps all the tree was a
writing list music sausage is
freestyling what did it start you to
break down I was in a sixth grade and
again I wasn't really always getting
good grades I was struggling in school
but I'm in a sixth grade and we're in
English class and the English teacher
says okay here's five words that all
rhyme I want you to make a poem out of
these words and everyone made their
poems and had to present it to the class
and when I remember when I got to my
poem I did mine and the whole class was
laughing because it was clever how I put
it together a teacher everybody and then
she was like no that's a good one that
was a really good one and that was like
kind of gave me a hint like okay maybe I
could rap a little bit maybe but I never
thought about it seventh grade I wrote
my first song I used to back home I used
to wear north face jackets I couldn't
afford one but I wanted one so bad but I
feel I wanted one so bad that I wrote a
song about it you feel me and I remember
I'll get I'll go to the lunch table and
I'll have somebody be like oh this is
the beat I'll show him the beat and I'll
be like do this beat and then I'll rap
the giant and then that was like my
first rap song so seventh grade
well 10th grade fast forward 10th grade
I was writing a little stuff I wanted to
be like wale and Kanye West and
everybody so I saw I'm writing basically
biting them right in the same way they
were writing stuff right and just like
them and then left it and I went to jail
the first time it was for four months
and I started doing like writing songs
like singing and there was a time where
like the guards everybody would ask me
to sing too and I would do that
and I left the wrapping thing alone when
I was in a go-go band so I was doing go
go ya know so I was in a go-go band
doing my thing before I got locked up so
I was taking that same mentality yeah
that stuff nowadays they were young
bands back yeah yeah yes yes they still
do it to this day it's actually probably
bigger than it's been in a while right
now yeah yeah it's a big movement going
on with that hahahaha yeah so boom in
jail right singing this stuff I get up
miss I'm in school everything trying to
get my life together violation I go back
in jail for two months my lawyer
couldn't get me out of jail I convinced
the the clerk's office to let me out
because I was in school I was doing good
I needed to like get my [ __ ] together I
don't need to be in jail I can come back
for my court date I'm not a flight risk
I'm talking to them every day okay
that's crazy so boom like I do that oh
and I get out so I'm out for two months
and then I go to jail for my court
hearing my initial sentence was three
years actually gave me two years over oh
damn they gave me they gave me 15
suspended - they gave me 15 years
suspended two three and I did three it
was supposed to be on home detention I
violated home detention after 2 years so
I had to do my last year in state prison
because usually if you if your sentence
is under 16 I mean 18 months you do it
in jail but my sentence was overall 3
years even though I only had a year left
so they sent me up the road the state
and I did that there and that's when I
like started rapping rapping like really
writing like really trying to like okay
let me like try to put these words
together let me try to make songs and
when I
the way I used to release music I used
to put that [ __ ] on YouTube and just
this high used to do it so on Facebook I
had a lot of friends on Facebook like
maybe 2,000 friends I would see who's
online and copy and paste yo-yo just
send it to everybody
mmm yo and then the people who will
respond I'll be like yo I just got this
I got this song I wanted you to check it
out I want to see what you think about
it and I would do that [ __ ] all day long
like all day like back-to-back see most
people would just send you the link and
go check my music out or just post
don't worry like that yeah because
that's BAM but if you say yo first then
it's like what's up and then you hit
them with they're more likely to pay
attention so that's what that's
literally how I started marketing my
music I mean I put my first song out and
in a day or two days they had a thousand
views and I'm like [ __ ]
a thousand people listen to this have
been exciting feeling huh oh yeah I'm
like damn that's what that was the first
spark remember I was talking about the
bait yeah that was the first name when I
would see those views and stuff on my I
maybe let me so I was trying to release
music once a week at first and then that
was just too much to do and then I I
remember I used to sell sneakers and
stuff and I remember I said I'm gonna
sell all these sneakers I'm gonna take
this money
i'ma holla at my boys we gonna put some
money in and we're gonna shoot a
legitimate video and my first video was
500 dollars it was this you know the
first video was $40 this this the second
video was 500 but it was good quality
everything looked cinematic and [ __ ] I'm
like damn this is tight I'll put that
out and it's accumulating views
accumulating views and then next thing
you know it's that 50,000 views and I'm
like damn this is working and I just
kept realizing that maybe I put quality
into my stuff
it'll happen faster I made a lot of
mistakes not everything worked but I
spent a lot of money but it brought me
to where I'm at here right now and over
the years I learned how to navigate the
business and if I didn't learn how to
navigate the business I wouldn't have
the record deal that I got right
I would have a regular artist deal
probably you feel me yeah what made you
let's go somewhere else
what made you ever wanted to be this be
a rapper yeah who did you see well give
you influence to say hey that's what can
be what make thing I think while they
honestly was the first one Kanye West 50
cent but these guys were like huge mega
stars they didn't feel accessible while
a was from whelmed from and I saw him
one day I was at I was getting piece and
he was at the piece of place and I'm
like damn this is why la like that was
accessible to me so I felt like I
probably would say he was the first one
to make me feel like I could probably do
this yeah and then as I started to get
bigger and starting to meet people and
know you know he gets a bigger big
artist that I've been like I thought
were unaccessible that made me really
feel like okay nobody I'm trying to say
right now what is the center the center
of it like um what makes you think that
people should come and get you okay what
makes you get that will give you
definitely acting forward almost
immediately so let me be one be happy
really I don't think I've ever said this
before us when I was a kid I used to get
made fun of I didn't have the shoes
[ __ ] was like I used to be depressed
going to school because I was so dark
skinned well I'm not even that dog thing
but people used to make fun of me
because I was too dark seriously like it
was about light skinned with like
cornrows and stuff like that so
everybody's making fun of me I make in
front of me cuz I'm African you know my
parents are from my mom's from Sierra
Leone my dad's from Ghana African people
make in front of me it made me not like
myself almost I feel you flex a question
cuz I'm a kid I don't know what's going
on I'm now looking back I'm like no kid
is supposed to feel like that you too
young to be thinking about feeling like
that I'm feeling depressed almost as a
kid because I don't want to go to school
and get made funny no that drives you to
become who you are exactly cuz then i
remember one day it I remember I used to
get one pair of shoes maybe two if you
know I might get another pair on
Christmas um uh year
seventh grade
I had some some chucks and I had some
Air Force Ones and then shits to the
ground and everybody's making fun of me
and then I remember my grandma brought
me to Charles Barkley's for Christmas
and I'm like I got some but they were
white so I was a big mistake but I was
this finessing them joints for a little
bit then eighth grade I had to go to
Pennsylvania because I was given you
know getting in trouble and stuff they
really sent me with my uncle
Pennsylvania Pittsburgh they don't like
the way we dress down there so they make
it in front of me even more and I had a
pair of Jordans that my friend had an
accident form just was [ __ ] fake so
one day i go to i go to i go to lunch
yeah the jump man was going the other
way
listen the jump man was going the
opposite way and somebody with the real
one and he was fat and you couldn't see
his fingers there was no detail I'm like
I knew they were fake though
at that point I already knew but I was
like China Fionn I was trying to cover
the back up you know if you don't see it
you won't know you know I mean man ace I
just remember everybody laughing behind
me and I look back and then somebody
comes and starts pointing at the back of
the joint and then a folk dance shoe
next to mine this is going in on me the
whole time all the girls everybody man I
cry did you cry I didn't cry I just I
felt bad though I remember that feeling
that Stan let me taste I was a little
kid one time and um I was skipping
school could they I kicked my ass in
school the day before so I was just go
to school for lunch and after lunch I
was walking around the school stare at a
neighborhood to school this out get my
books and I used to go home want to see
the people they kick my ass earlier and
so I'm in Brooklyn New York and so when
three four kids came over there they see
you got any money I'm saying no I'm
probably dying it so ten years uh no
it's all we finally keeps her to check
my pocket with no money and so the guy
said you wanna fly with us and I say
yeah I don't know a [ __ ] fly me six
climb the fence they give us those
create the milk crates I was trying to
say let's do and so they walk with me
and so they they go in the buildings in
the bitter when abandoned bills I don't
know these guys are too son to me
[ __ ] kill me rape I don't know I'm
sick
kid you know some gold is building me go
on the rules and see the birds and
pigeons just a wire and some of the all
day I'm psyched with the pigeons and a
bird [ __ ] on my guitar on me I got dirt
on me all day and they think I'm going
to the sinner tonight they got a chance
me I didn't know anything even to a
party if I'm ten years old nine years I
never been to a jam I know that stuff is
at the center so I go there not knowing
that I should have went home and war I
never washed before I don't know nothing
about changing I only go to school and
when I went that I still had to [ __ ] on
me the tar from the pinnacle and so
everybody was lose this dirty
[ __ ] y'all know this [ __ ] man
who the [ __ ] is this dirty nasty funky
ass [ __ ] right and I was I was crying
but I was laughing too but I was crying
I was just scared and so I remember um
one of the guys this is the older guys
the friend of one of those guys that
said you won't find me brothers if they
shut the [ __ ] I hate but meet me at the
pigeon coop tomorrow morning it's not
one of them so he came I was there
tomorrow morning went to the pigeon coop
next morning and so he was there so he
took me someplace he knocked on his door
first away answer the door so he took me
in the back and he opened the one and he
put me in the window and he said open
the door [ __ ]
and I went over though we robbed the
house they were guns there was money was
robbed stuff I was just ten to nine
years old but I didn't know what had so
I remember he didn't give me much money
give me like five bucks or five dollars
a rock bed yeah but it was here to give
you father he did something he went and
took me shopping I bought me a bunch of
clothes he said make sure you coming to
[ __ ] sin on Saturday [ __ ] and
see what the [ __ ] make sure you wear
this [ __ ] I bought and I came today and
remember I was the same person
yeah people laugh they never know the
same person they were around me talking
to me I know I was that person they
would laugh that made fun of told me
nasty stinking [ __ ] bump
they didn't know who I was yeah who was
that guy and I could probably dead down
yeah [ __ ] it showed me that people with
materialistic
right and they didn't remember me how
could you not remember me using milli
ate me like a week ago right they didn't
remember me I come out different cuz I
look like a Mac I had Pierre card and
all that's [ __ ] weeded tweeted pan so
I had a [ __ ] long Jean watching I'm
ten years old [ __ ] damn yeah that and
that's funny because literally that
they've great night time but couldn't
[ __ ] tell time
do you understand I'm saying though I
had to look this way this how you have
to look to be accepted right all right I
can't tell [ __ ] time no I have that
watch that is of a chain has at the pier
car damn that my tailor suits I had then
he took me to the tailor made me a
[ __ ] suit that pads on the pocket on
my side and [ __ ] it was crazy in the 70s
Mega Man 77 76 can't believe that that's
my life I gotta rob and still to have to
make happy doesn't mean to be respect to
have to hurt people
mmm daddy we had to rob them maybe kills
them
mmm for people to respect if I don't do
that I'm [ __ ] food they've taken all
my [ __ ] I think my money take my clothes
my sneakers everything right if I don't
do that they don't see me doing that
being an animal did it they're gonna
feed on me right right they're not crazy
if they think like that that's what I'm
saying you have to be a kid in limited
environment that's crazy yeah I ain't
know it's all about fear if you got just
cutting these [ __ ] shooting and
making these people afraid of you
they're gonna do it to you right I feel
that bro that's why I was saying like
were me like that little that that
literally naive gray going in a knife I
said I'm not gonna be that person
anymore
I'm gonna figure out how to give some
money I'm gonna figure out how to get
some nice clothes and I know buddy's
never gonna make fun of me for not being
able that's what I said that's it the
same thing ever again I said the same
thing yeah and then once when I realize
what life is about life is about giving
everything away you know anything that
you feel you love you have to give it
away anything you feel you can't do
without you got to give it away when I
when I go in on the told no one I
realized would all comes back to it all
comes back to getting on your knees and
praying worshiping realizing that we're
nothing you know the elements is
everything yeah I say to myself how can
I did I even think I my car to see I'm
[ __ ] that guard I think I'm a kid
leader Alexander what the [ __ ] is on my
mind am i delusional Who am I what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me
yeah am i so small I want to be so big I
think a [ __ ] delusional [ __ ] damn
that's really you know as real as [ __ ] I
am
I feel scared I have to be a [ __ ]
monster Who am I afraid of one of my
favorite raid of myself hmm I want to be
a bad guy toughing me monster well
nobody know how much I'm afraid
mmm yeah that's true
that's real I was gonna ask you when you
um got into boxing right I guess it's
like you do amateur boxing at first
right so as an amateur like were you
like beating everybody no no no that
wouldn't be I've lost faith but I was I
was uh I was very good cuz I they taught
me a little I learned quick and I was
really for ocean and violent and
unpredictable and use mean and so people
would take the kids out of the
tournament they won't let me fight their
kids so I have to fight older people all
the time all right so my 14 13 I have to
fight a guy 28 28 years old
damn so when you wanted your first big
match what was that the big one first
big one national championship in 1980
and you won that and you want a lot of
money for that no I didn't win any money
but the whole um the country no world
saw me fight ah you know in all the
boxing people I like boxing Pro fighting
it stood watching up-and-coming people
and they were very excited about seeing
me I was very um a very reckless kind of
guy hmm how many years into boxing was
that for you like from when from when
you started to get to that first
national championship on one yeah when
one year yes they were like 14 and
knocked everybody out you were 14 yeah
and I stayed about one round Wow as fast
I had an incredible train I had a master
trainer yeah
costea Monty's incredibly he worked my
psychic my feelings didn't mean nothing
to me nothing meant only thing manages
my glory in my objective my objective
was to madame annihilate somebody mm-hmm
and the more I night later I had a
little self-esteem and he told me if you
don't feel you love this the more the
more in annihilate these people the more
the world will love you mmm
so it goes back to that thing we've
talked about here you've said about the
importance of the ego because without
your own ego you'll just get [ __ ] on
your home yeah you know because no one
is gonna stand up for you or do anything
for you other than yourself at the end
of the day everyone else around you has
ideas about who they think you are and
what they think you should be doing yeah
yeah so the good thing about the ego is
that that gives us the strength to stand
up for ourselves and to find the
confidence to go and do what you did you
know do you feel like because you had so
many fights on the street as a kid
before getting to meet cus that he just
plugged in the mental attitude portion
honey yes honey you throw a fit where
you come from they could fight it
somewhere you come nobody problem with
you come he made me he gave me pride and
dignity and gave me a ego where I came
from I know I don't want people to know
I came up around this book I'm so
ashamed to be for these [ __ ] negativo
savages it's all used to be so proud to
be from there yeah what tough fight at
all great fighters come from there they
don't know xx the Jews in the twenties
and stuff yeah and he was just telling
me that he's always made me proud of
myself in like then next thing you know
you give you a co you go get so far you
do you forgot please humble me God can
y'all your Eagles are Street income you
straight confrontation with God that's
what it is
mmm is that direct confrontation with
God yeah that's real it's damn nice in
real that's really really rare it's good
it's good stuff I mean that's real yeah
that's the balance hey you know we don't
really when I'm hitting I'm young and
stuff cars gonna do what to me come at
me I'm invincible look at me God gave me
this to be this way and then you get 50
years old no you do is take off please
have mercy on my soul I get 50 years old
I'm scared I won't go at that Marissa
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't ask for
mercy yeah all I should I do now I'm
scared I'm asked for mercy skin it's
getting close to meetings art I need
what can I do now
get the money but what kind of another
bite from mercy off for you what you
think the wildest thing you've done I
will say what you think the wildest
thing you've done that you need the most
merciful is always a lot that you can't
even God knows yeah I was gonna say so
alright back to this money thing know
what is your like experience when you
first saw your first million dollars Wow
know what I did with it
yeah what like how did you feel about it
was you know what I mean did it even hit
you or it just was like whatever no um I
want my mind was already in the sit that
that's nothing know who I am you know
what I'm gonna make
I was always in the ego was taking over
without even knowing mm-hmm you know
yeah you was young it's nothing [ __ ]
that's all I'm getting I wanted the
money those all the guys got I wonder
the Olympians when they got my [ __ ] that
I want more mom better than everybody
why do they got much comparing myself
with everybody everything I compare my
now I'm the best of all the fighting I
let me see I want to compare with all
other the table so I make more money
than them then I beat them that what
about their owns in the past what about
car what about that king katar 20 dear
thousand years ago am I better than him
hmm
now why did I stir who what made me who
gave me an inclination to think like
that
why am I thinking like who the [ __ ] am I
my mother the first my father Who am I
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are
you but it's still Queens if I think I'm
somebody mm-hmm yeah yeah well you are
somebody and you're nobody
yeah you better remember that nobody a
lot though yeah you know [ __ ] you
think I wanna be rain with a killer the
[ __ ] make you a [ __ ] [ __ ] I should
be begging you should be begging to be
[ __ ] frogs every day finish it you
think you know if you can't never forget
um our whole life is just to be humble
right
let me call God um so I made this to
Humble us because we think we're
somebody yeah cuz I'm a nobody always
wanted to be a somebody
you know yeah I think I think that's
exactly kind of what gave me the
encouragement to be what I became so
much of getting beat up in the sense as
a kid verbally mentally and like [ __ ]
like not [ __ ] with certain exactly
and you feel like you wanted other guys
that nobody definitely not until you
been I've seen up to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
leave it woman I don't say to Ben I
could you Maddie took your [ __ ] yeah I
wanted to be like those guys
mmm you know those guys I'm not even
made to be like those guys I want to be
like them so bad it's not even in my
blood of my bones to be like them but I
would be like them so bad when I kiss
their feet or worship them I want to be
like something I'm nobody
crazy right we'll do a [ __ ]
Mike yeah let's take that thing of so
what you're maybe this is the
conversation with this is the
hypothetical conversation with God
you're having okay you're doing really
well you're treating your family well
you're doing well in business you're
spreading some good into the world and
some positive but do you think we forgot
about that all that other [ __ ] so in
your mind what what is it is it some
punishment that's coming is it some
reckoning as a what is it that God is me
I need to be more humbled I need to
build my needs more I believe that's
what I believe I believe I should be and
that's okay there's that's okay to
constantly have the robot I think that
why do I get these [ __ ] what's those
things that the psychiatrist called um
those mantras sorts of diamo thought the
[ __ ] angel and you thought about what
I'm [ __ ] about ruling the world
well because you aspire to a great thing
and thinking that my my Heights
potential to be when I don't exist
anymore
yeah that's great
but at the end of the day don't you
think that God whoever that is is gonna
welcome you with open arms
I don't know any ones I should to stop
in my head I want those voices to stop
which voices the banjo voices yeah I
don't know man well we're here to do
[ __ ] you know we're here to have an
experience we're not here to just sit
around and [ __ ] twiddle our thumbs
and jerk off you know we're here to do
things we're here to put energy out
right how do we know we hit those veins
really actually you know because now I
realize now that there's something going
on that I use them can't put my foot
absolutely at my finger this Sun going
under define me that I just can't put my
finger up so right I mean you think God
called me to see if my leaders be living
up there now we don't exist anymore what
did he make up for that for what what
kind of image what did we leave behind
what it must be just some quality he
wants for us and say hey that's all I
need I
sending ones that we do when we exist
yeah and he needs us all for a certain
part we all need to play a part for this
part of the world while survive and now
it's over and I was going to the other
part of it did that make sense when we
go down here why haven't all the people
when we die when I'm to the people that
was next to us driving the cars the
world P we looked and stuff that girl
may be firing Carly Here I am to those
people where were they in our life we
only met them 4/10 of a second why would
an eye like why would they driving next
to us what is it all about I have those
thoughts all the time who knows wow that
meant to feed that girl faith in the car
at a guy in his family in the car I've
thought about this lately anywhere I am
in this office out at a restaurant
driving around it's amazing to think
about how every human being at some
point maybe they still do and they do
they have dreams and visions for
themselves an idea
about what they want to do with their
lives yeah and everybody has something
sacred you know we get so diluted with
all these people around us and [ __ ]
you know you're driving in traffic and
you're trying to make something of
yourself that you forget that we're all
just human beings here man
with ideas about what we want to do with
our time yeah it's like [ __ ] that means
something that means a lot oh wait say I
wonder what that person's thinking right
now
you know I see something in the car it's
towards my death wonder what that
thinking hmm it means a lot all of this
means something and maybe there's
obviously meant to happen if it's
ordained to happen if this is the course
this video is just meant that before
like ten thousand years ago this was
ordained to happen this is already in
their written into the cosmos but it is
deep man life is [ __ ] deep life is
deep you know and through I believe
cultural brainwashing the system of life
having to get a job to survive to make
money to put food on the table it's
distracted us and it's made us all
[ __ ] really cynical about what we're
doing here and the meaninglessness of
this life which is wrong before we got
to civilizations all we did was voice
show yeah every everything we did they
thought about God yeah oh no it's crazy
what I was watching this thing I don't
know where it was on YouTube and it's
about this guy who or this village of
people who are basically like cavemen
almost I don't know the right correct
word but they were living happily with
like no clothes
they were used making their own stuff
everything was good right
and this white guy comes and he's like
he comes to the place he's filming
everything and he introduces himself he
learns their language and everything and
then he starts giving them money and
then they take the money and walk miles
and miles and miles to the market and
start buying stuff and then either
coming back with radios and now he needs
batteries and he needs all of these
things to listen to his radio he likes
music all of this stuff right but now he
needs money so he's asking this guy
every time yo I need some money to go
get this then he starts making up lies I
need money to do this but he'll take the
money and do something else and now the
next one is I need money like he's like
needs money now he got clothes now like
raggedy kind of clothes but it's still
clothes now all of this stuff shorts
whatever he's like nah I need money to
get a boat so I can get to the market
faster but the white guy's like nah I
can't if I give this guy a boat they're
gonna move their economy is gonna grow
too fast because they can move too
quickly between town and back and forth
this guy's like no I can't do that
he's like man I need a thousand whatever
it is rupees or something like that cuz
it's like near India he's like nah man I
can't do this I can't do this I can't do
this I mean the guy [ __ ] he comes no
he comes back he threatens to kill him
he gets the whole village to turn
against them he says you can't leave
this village until you give me my money
he's like tripping you know what I mean
not letting this dude leave the camera
crew everybody's in danger now
eventually they say you know what I give
him the money they give him the money
they roll he goes and everything is I
don't know what's going on now but you
see they were happy when they didn't
have [ __ ] yeah this [ __ ] comes and
introduces them to money and look what
the [ __ ] is going on E is the root of
all evil that's what my last video I
just dropped today it's basically about
the misunderstanding of money right I
think that's more accurate for sure
money in order to handle money is a
heart but think about this though how
many people know how to handle money
versus not know how to
so it still lives the root of all evil
there's a few people that get it very
few but not a lot of people get that
listen Noah this is how the game is
played the Monday the work the wealth
got is so big it's bigger than ever
there's been last year the world right
right and it's the people um what I see
the masses get used to it like in the
poor African country right um they don't
expect nothing they stop expecting
things and when you stop expecting
things you happy see guys like us we
expect [ __ ] you know I expect to go
someplace they're gonna pay me for my
time I expect them to lace me all the
great hotel great limousine a
rolls-royce good food have them give me
some extra money if I was doing drugs
back then I'd make sure they have them
[ __ ] drugs ready make sure they have
some [ __ ] for me if I was that way
back then and it's just that's the way
it was mmm you know yeah no I we
definitely expect and that story of that
guy's like a low level of what
expectation can do you feel sad like my
life I don't expect anything yeah you
know me don't expect anything right I
got I don't know if you would expect a
gift I have a gift for you yes yeah cool
it's time I got this gift is a special
gift that it took some thought because
I'm it's something that I like to look
at old man I don't know about that well
I know a little bit about the toads I
know about the toads but I also know
about the pigeons you know I know you
like the toes and stuff you know what
I'm saying
I found out about I found that out a
little after I already got the gift for
you but I want to bring it in honestly
bro I don't even like
beautiful yeah [ __ ] oh no they can
you look you know better than me perform
we got it from whatever whatever
whatever got to get done you for me but
he's a cool tree he was flying all over
the place the other day
I'm yesterday at you know we didn't
catch him I'll be bottom we bought her
oh yeah yeah in the room and stuff it's
a cool bird so you gonna name him you
got a name for him no problem bro
for sure it's really beautiful but um
yeah that was unexpected
yeah I wanted to ask you about this
piece you got yes it's beautiful thank
you this black diamonds crystals called
a to see stone um well I haven't done
research on exactly where it's from but
I got it from a jewelry store see I had
this thing of um I know right now it's
like a lot about white gold and all that
stuff and and diamonds and things like
that but for me I felt like I wanted to
be more into different types of stones
that look beautiful you know what I mean
I just felt like I said he's more unique
thing to do when this look comes from
Mansa Musa yeah and richest man in the
world right my son took one of those
those tests who he was in the previous
life and that's who he was
this is how I become a billionaire
scripture how to become a billionaire is
our trash you weren't about before
but let's go back though you said how I
feel about this Rolex right to be honest
the more I look at it the more I have it
I don't really feel [ __ ] like I used to
like wanna have a Rolex and have
different watches and stuff because I
was like one of the things like you know
growing up like everybody you know I'm
saying yeah and I got one and I got
actually got two of them and I mean it's
just whatever it's whatever it's almost
to be honest with you there was a time
where I'm like man Rolex ain't [ __ ] I
wanna ap now I want dude and it's like
my mind is already starting to think
like that I gotta tone it down because
it's like life you have to tone it down
because like it's only gonna lead to
wanting more and more and more who do
you want to be there you know how do you
have twenty seventy cents when he said
so who do you how do you who do you want
to be that thing 35 what do you want to
do what you do when I'm 35 penis of your
life most of your life is all when you
have to copy your game who do you want
to be what do you want to be I think one
thing I'm China what's that look like
yeah one thing I want to do is two
things I wanted the RET movies that's
one of the things that I'm like when I'm
35 is funny exactly what I'm 35 is when
I kind of want to be into that and an
other thing I want to do is I want to
eventually open up some type of animal
sanctuary I don't want to say a zoo I
want to kind of rep out what you want to
do that you love animals I love animals
I used to have Birds I used to have
cockatiels I used to have I had doves I
had what's those African bird that talk
back to Oh African Grey parrot
but I just like turtles and [ __ ] like
all types of different animals I like I
used to love watching Animal Planet a
[ __ ] so pretty much that's one of the
things I want to do I want to get into
like impact investments so basically
invest in things that make an impact in
the world you know what I mean that's
like like isolate right DVD or CBD oh
yeah it's a future of medicine right
there
CBD that's my house everyone so it's the
future of medicine maybe I need that
[ __ ] for my [ __ ] knees we all been
playing basketball lately and [ __ ] that
money yeah yeah I'm starting to get
there hey oh I always actually like
wisdom amount of money do you think you
want where you'll be like I'm good right
a lot of people say I want everything I
don't want to stop what is everything
there's nothing there's no such thing is
everything it's like you'll be you it's
definitely not gonna happen in your
lifetime yeah no but this is this is how
it goes and I don't know why it goes
like that
yeah I don't know if we got everything
we want we kill ourselves I feel like
the more money you you get what we are
purposely more you are no purpose after
we change our life is over was my
purpose for life was my purpose for
living [ __ ] don't mean almost nothing
to me anymore money doesn't mean much to
me and will don't mean any my kids don't
mean it have everything they mean
nothing that's all about me well it's my
purpose I want to meet God come on
yeah I bring gold I see I ain't get that
far bro I didn't get to the guy part I
think like I believe in God but I don't
think I ever had a point in my life
where I thought I was above God or I was
gonna you know compete with him I never
got that far
but I definitely there was a times where
I was like yeah I want all this money I
want all this but it's like for what
what do you want it for like you know
it's funny when you start making money
right when I was when I was when I had
no money twenty dollars for some food
made a dent in my pocket right okay and
I get to a point in my career where I'm
making you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars food doesn't do [ __ ] no like
unless I'm eating that Nobu every single
day or some [ __ ] like food don't really
hurt me there gets a point where your
money gets so big buying a car doesn't
really hurt you boy that's cool too
right right
check out what goes like this huh man
you get to live well you don't like food
no more mmm you don't like food you get
to a level you don't like food the
pleasure killing me now I never gained
from oh no I'm not quitting inside my
body I can't fit my pants ah got you I
can't get in my clothes
yeah yeah I feel embarrassed now right
right two fat people are looking at me
mMmmm I'm not gonna eat never [ __ ]
get in my life cuz I wanna kill wanna
die yeah yeah people are laughing at me
hmm well you reach that point with
everything don't you Mike yeah this is
what I am sure no listen this is so I
have a lot to do I was talking to my
wife anything I'm saying while I was
slightly crying because I we we love
each other and I said to myself the
reason why I never went back to anybody
else in my relationships and my ex my ex
was because I was too ashamed mm-hmm
there's no way I could live with the
mess that I did all that [ __ ] to though
I could be with my I couldn't trust him
again I didn't trust Bo it was just so
scary and I just gave him to I gave my
life into shame I can't do this no more
so I was going to new people because
after [ __ ] I been doing me please yeah
oh you can't never trust yourself you
can't trust these people you feel so bad
you've been do you did this to them oh
my god
to be which I got to go back mmm this is
crazy
mmm you can never trust yourself anymore
you know I thought you always you know
guys like that's when we've come from
worried someone you know regardless
you're middle-class we rarely get a
chance to know how to love ourselves
yeah well come how do you love yourself
really I always thought loving myself
with always getting the best girl right
getting a nice car
get a nice suit go eating my food I
thought that was loving myself that was
destroying myself Oh killing myself
I was trying I was killing myself to
live yeah you know the time to live yeah
I think that's a really important
question how do we love ourselves how do
you do that how do you love this thing
when you say well no this is bad I'm not
gonna eat all of it or something like
that I'm not gonna drink all of that I'm
not gonna sniff all of that hmm you know
I mean how do you how do you do that
when you're at my job when your
personality is all out I gotta go all
out I can't live if I don't do it all
I've died but what is it that makes you
feel like you gotta go all out I don't
know what is it maybe maybe it's just um
my mortality
will you die from this you do it all
[ __ ] I don't know that's where we all
have to ask yeah no thanks yeah man
that's a hard question no like outside
of those things that I want to
accomplish I mean I don't I don't know I
think there was a point in my time in my
life and I probably get back to this
where I just when it's all said and done
I wanted a family that loves me you know
what I mean and I wanted to create an
environment better than what I kind of
grew up around you know what I mean but
it wasn't really a lot of love or
affection being shown regardless you
know you came from the situation you
came from
I came from the situation I came from
but they're similar in a lot of
different ways you feel me I think that
I wanted I think that was my ultimate
goal even if I was like I would take
having like making like five hundred
thousand a year or something and having
a family over being multi-millionaire
and
not ever having it you know Naveen so I
think that's what I always wanted to
strive for right now I'm kind of so
focused on what I'm doing right now I
know that that will come so I'm not like
rushing to do that you see anything but
I think later on I'll get back to that
kind of thought process where that'll be
probably my ultimate goal to have a
family in you know reproduce and be able
to teach my kids and things that I may
not have learned and try my best to
steer them in the right direction so
they can do the same and the legacy can
continue you for me that's kind of
probably what eventually I'm gonna get
back to well I want to go back to one
thing you said now yeah because you
talked about what's an AP and another
watch yeah and I'm on your lie and you
caught yourself you were you said oh
well I kind of need to pull the reins
back on that yeah it's not so much like
well let me let me throw this out there
because I know Mike has some thoughts on
this too and you know as we are in the
flow of life you know yeah and the real
point is to be able to live moment to
moment whatever that means right so
maybe it doesn't matter if you are
living your life to the fullest in the
moment that you find yourself in or if
you're constantly living in the moment
to the point where you're analyzing
every thought you have about what you
want to do for yourself or what's the
next step or what's the next thing I can
buy because maybe that's what I want you
know and then at the end of the day you
know you're gonna find yourself
somewhere else and then and then what
you know are you gonna feel bad about
buying the watch are you gonna feel bad
about not letting yourself buy the watch
oh and at the end of and when all of
that settles you know really all were
left with is what was did I make the
best decision in the moment that I
possibly
do you think like that though based on I
feel like that ourself something as
simple as a simple as maybe getting a
watch maybe not I will buy certain
things and be like damn maybe I could
have put this money here or did this
with this money but never like I never
dwell on it too much
I think cuz you know I find a way to
make it back or it comes back in a
different way or whatever the case may
be the thing might make me happy for the
moment but like right now I got to watch
okay it's cool I'm kind of already like
tired of when I made it to the league I
got my first check yeah I got myself a
BMW 750 li and I got myself was
beautiful beautiful machine making a
beautiful car and then I bought myself
[ __ ] Breitling it was ten plus
thousand dollars yeah dude I probably
wore that watch six times Wow and I
realized I don't even like watches but I
was following some idea about what
you're supposed to do with your money
and how you're supposed to look when you
have money 100% you know what's funny
when you first get to watch right you
want everybody to see it and and it
looks like in this you could tell people
respect you differently when you have a
look at you different look at you
differently over this watch like after a
while it doesn't even you don't really
even notice it anymore yeah but you meet
me you might meet this girl and she's
like beautiful and she's acting so nice
to you and [ __ ] and everything is good
and you forget you got this watch you
forget you got a nice crib you forget on
Instagram you got this many father all
that [ __ ] and you just think oh yes cuz
it you know I'm saying you're like you
it's cause of me about all of that [ __ ]
like that you have home I used to think
I'm a [ __ ] killing the way I dare
take my [ __ ] with me and not to mention
you chill out either killer okay it's
chill hey what's up brother
right he's I was um I was a megalomaniac
yeah I was somebody yeah
you know I feel like duh yeah I don't
like that you know
in fact so maybe you can do it how you
want to do it now you know that's what
this is all about maybe you can do it
free of any expectation or what somebody
else has done or what some idea you had
ten years ago about what it looks like
yeah and you can just do it the way you
want to do absolutely dumb guys them I
didn't feel like I deserved it for some
reason no dude I went through that stage
I got a list this [ __ ] guy I don't
got [ __ ] I'm on no good [ __ ] [ __ ]
and this is kind of a good guy and I got
this and I don't got that hmm hmm that's
a trip that's a trip looking true as a
true good guy I think about this you
live in a hood right okay somebody comes
and robs you from another hood you have
to kill that [ __ ] yes because if you
don't kill him everybody gonna feel like
they can rob so now you kill this dude
you kill him his neighborhood is like
okay we gave him you let me first of all
I'm already mad you killed my boy but
then I'll let you come and kill my
people if I don't do nothing now
everybody's gonna see look at me like
nah we can come over there and do
whatever we want to these guys crazy
it's crazy so now it's a back and forth
back and forth back and forth and then
never stop never get involved with years
later the kids might squash it it could
be something as simple as they going to
school and a [ __ ] step on it your
students from the wrong place and say
the wrong thing to you when he does it
and now it's a fight okay it's a fight
the new thing now is negative we don't
fight you know I'm saying it's fighting
there's not cool no more you got a kid
or somebody that's but just what it is
that's how you really show who you are
oh but they have to learn to love each
other that's what doc that's what we're
loving each other that's what I'm trying
to beat each other differently with
respect and dignity 100% how do you tell
a kid that kids growing up you learning
the concept of respect as a man is
because if he lives long enough he will
learn it yeah I hunt if he have a chance
to live longer god bless him with the
ability to live so turn to H you will
learn humility he would learn Keith he
would learn love 100% and put away his
gun and he would somebody kill him for
God could take a soul mercy on his soul
right right
I mean you think listen you think these
guys feeling real do you think they
really feel good about themselves didn't
kill some people some people say [ __ ]
the Nicky dessert but you think they
really feel bad when they're low
management that loan they have their
demons with knowing no one's around
myself and my demons start talking to me
as people we're not put on his earth to
kill each other that's not what we're
built for I know I agree hundred percent
certain people that might do it
might have gone through certain
traumatic things I make it easier for
them to do that but nobody's supposed to
do that we're not here for that you know
I mean you know young young lady from
noise man we're bonded I know we're not
wanting to kill and I know upon the love
respect
I represent you know what I love my
respect as real as hell yeah man J it's
been awesome and I appreciate you having
me beautiful happy nice fun oh yeah
great show man yes still time DK
everybody yes everybody first of all
second of all he want something you want
some advice huh from a guy who think he
was a player hmm monk yeah yeah go ahead
um nah Valachi the women hmm you're
telling the truth hmm you will have you
you listen oh you you you have no idea
how much power that you have yeah
tell me the truth yeah and listen to
that bull Shafter you telling the truth
buddy can they have to submit to the
truth I don't care who powerful me yeah
submit to the truth right right right
how mad they offer for long they gotta
film it to the truth right right the
truth the truth of the guard you have to
submit to that right right damn that's
real
I appreciate it listen this is an honor
to be up here
I've been forward swish I told the truth
yeah yeah the second though the truth
absolutely third that time the truth
okay they can respect be respected so
they don't like but they respect it
right they they don't respect them I
won't they don't respect the right they
don't respect you right yeah Femmes man
it's been real man thank you guys man we
appreciate you a shout out idk idk is he
real on a way yeah you really see real
real real
he said I'm real he said I'm real sorry
the [ __ ] real dog hmm
you can't worry about people people
don't know we don't know it realize we
don't know what is we don't know what is
real
we don't know dream what is this real
this [ __ ] I don't know I don't know yeah
this is real I don't know you dream too
we don't know our purpose we've been put
here for a reason that we have no idea
what it is Thanks yeah you know just
enjoying the ride that's all right one
moment to the next
all right everybody yeah [ __ ] great
episode great awesome episode hey be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
hot boxing with Mike Tyson and I
appreciate you guys i'm evan britain
with my brother mike our new brother IDK
in the house thank you guys so much
thank you until next time drinking
amigos this bird gonna get high baby
okay
endocannabinoids hi a bird I kept
smoking with any football yeah it's not
bad for damn alright y'all I until next
time peace
[Music]